this fishing line may be thin but that
doesn't mean it's not strong
it's made of a synthetic called
ultra-high molecular weight polyethylene
this same synthetic is used in milk jugs
water pipes and even bulletproof vests
to make these fishing lines numerous
microfibers are braided into a single
tight cord
an employee starts by threading fibers
through needles she pulls the needles
through spring-loaded devices the
devices keep the fibers and an even
tension as they unwind onto small
bobbins these bobbins are designed to
fit in the braiding machines the
machines are called maple graders
because the spools spin like dancers
around a maypole as they spin they weave
the strands into a tight braid
producing a tight braid is slow work big
spools overhead slowly revolved to take
up the braided polyethylene line at the
same time a worker fills the metal tank
with hot water and adds yellow dye to it
a pump at the bottom of the tank keeps
the water moving to evenly distribute
the dye he stirs it a bit while he
inspects the mixing job they heat and
pressurized the dye in a tank filled
with fishing line the dye penetrates all
of the strands for an even dye job these
fishing lines go through a different
process they unwind through metal
eyelets into a tray of yellow silicon
resin this proprietary resin makes the
line abrasion resistant it will be less
likely to break if dragged across a
surface like a rock
next the line travels through an oven to
cure the resin
it travels over a series of tensioning
rollers as it exits then the line goes
through an abrasive eyelet which removes
external contaminants finally it's
rolled up by a spool an automated system
now transfers the line to retail sized
spools it loads about 450 feet of line
onto each one a worker applies a label
with product details and packages it in
a cardboard box it takes about 17 days
to braid color and process a single
spool of synthetic fishing line strong
but very thin it can be cast and reeled
in with ease
you